[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الخاصه
من النقاش المغاربه قالت لي نعود فيها
بمناسبه نهايه السنه وبدايه السنه الجديده
نعود فيها على ابرز القضايا التي طبعت
المشهد المغاربي خلال السنه المنقذيه
وابدا بالترحيب بضيوفه من الجزائر العاصمه
مع الدكتور فريد بن يحيى الخبير في
الاقتصاد والعلاقات الدوليه من الرباط
ارحب بالدكتوره المساوي العجلاوي الاستاذ
والباحث في مركز افريقيا والشرق الاوسط لي
الدراسات على ان ينضم الينا بعد قليل
الدكتور رافع طبيب الاستاذه في العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه بجامعه منوبه
سينضم الينا من تونس العاصمه ساده الكرام
اهلا بكم معنا على قناه
سنبدا بالعلاقات المغربيه الجزائريه ولا
تحسن شاهدته هذه العلاقات خلال السنه
المنقضيه منذ القطيعه الدبلوماسيه بينهما
رغم الاعمال التي كانت معقوده على القمه
العربيه التي احتضنتها الجزائر مع تداول
اخبار عن حضور محتمل العاهل المغربي محمد
السادس ومع غيابه ملك المغرب يبقى التوتر
سيد الموقف بين الجارتين رغم حديث كل طرف
من جهه عن استعداده للحوار استعداد للحوار
يتوازن مع سباق النحو التسلخ بين الدولتين
الجزائر ضاعفت في هذا السياق ماذا نيتها
للدفاع للسنه المقبله مثلا فما هي افاق
العلاقات بين البلدين بعض القطيعه التي
شهدتها وسؤال الرئيسي الذي نطرحه اذن في
هذا النقاش نقاش نهايه السنه ستبدا معك
دكتور مسوي العجلاوي من المغرب وتحديدا من
الرباط
العلاقات وصلت الى حد القطيعه بين الجزائر
والمغرب كل طرف كما استمعنا يقول لانه
مستعد للحوار لكن المراقبون يعتبرون بان
التوتر الذي بلغته العلاقات هو الاعلى في
تاريخ الدولتين ااه ما رايك في هذه النقطه
يعني عند الحديث عن العلاقات المغربيه
الجزائريه
التوتر طويله جدا فترات انفراج قصيره جدا
وكل اتفاقات التي وقعت حسن الجوار واتفاق
الحدود 1972
وبناء اتحاد المغرب العربي الكبير جاء في
فتره انفراج الان لا يمكن ان نقول ان
العلاقات بين المغرب والجزائر سيئه جدا
العلاقات الرسميه بين الدولتين ليست على
ما يرام بيتوتر ممكن نقول كبير اليه كبير
جدا لكن العلاقات بين الشعبين المغربي
والجزائري علاقات جيده تمتد في التاريخ
وفي
المشترك وفي العادات وفي التقاليد وما همم
ردود الفعل الشعب الجزائري انتصارات التي
حققها المنتخب المغربي في مونديال قطر الا
نموذج لهذا التقارب ويكفيه ان ندخل الى
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي معرفه ان التوتر
هو توتر رسمي ما الاسباب لا يمكن ان نصل
في حدود برنامج تنفيذي في قناه تلفزيه ان
نحدد هذه الاسباب لكن هناك اشكالات قويه
واشكالات معقده جدا تعود الى
1962 تعود الى بناء الدوله في الجزائر
تعود ايضا الى
الاثار الاستعمال الفرنسي في في المنطقه
فالمغرب يعني همم اقول ان المغرب من خلال
من همم خلال خطب الملكيه اخر واخا خطاب
العرش قال همم الملك محمد السادس يوجه
خطابه الى الشعب فريق قال لان المغرب لن
يمس ابدا الجزائر باي سوق وانه حول الحبوب
المساويه
من تصاعد التوتر نحو الصدام بين البلدين
خاصه في ظل التصلح الذي همم يتوجه نحوه
البلدان هل همم هذا وارد برايك ام ان مثلا
بالنسبه للمغرب مساله المواجهه مع الجزائر
باتت وراء المملكه
لم يشهر ابدا ورقه
التدخل العسكري او المواجهه العسكريه
بالعكس همم الملك محمد السادس مره اخرى
ترحاب قال
لتحاور وترك للطرف الجزائري اقتراح
هذه الاليه لا لن تجده سيدتي ابدا في
الخطاب الرسمي او الشعبي اداء بعد
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي لا حدود لها
ان هناك تشيرا بالورقه لا اعتقد لسببين ان
الحرب بين البلدين ستؤدي الى كارثه
المغاربيه ستعود بالوبال على الدوله ان
الدول الكبرى لم تسمح ابدا بنشوف حرب بين
المغرب والجزائر في غرب المتوسط لان ما
يجري الشرق المتوسط الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيا
يعني الخريطه الجو السياسيه الجديده لن
تسمح بهذا ولل يعني الجميع يتفق لانه لن
تكون هناك حرب بين المغرب والجزائر هذه
النقطه تحدي
بن يحيى من الجزائر العاصمه سمعت اينما
قاله السيد الموسوي العجلاوي من الرباط
اكيد هو اكد على ان العلاقه بين الشعبين
تبقى ممتازه ان هناك علاقه متميزه استشهد
طبعا في هذا الايثار في هذا الايطار بما
حدث خلال مونديال لكن العلاقات الرسميه
تبقى متوتره جدا
والمراقبني الجزائري والمغربي قد يظهر له
بان الموضوع اصبح حرب
بين الدولتين في المنطقه ليس فقط حرب بسبب
الاسباب المعروفه همم في التوتر العلاقات
بين دولهتين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وعلى العلاقات الجزائريه المغربيه فهي
علاقات متوتره نعم حاليا لكن في الجزائر
او في العمق الجزائري نؤمن كثير
احتلت من طرف الاستعمار الفرنسي الجزائر
افريقيا
لكن
في ازمه ثقه مع المغرب
ان الرئيس الفرنسي
الاوضاع وكذلك تصل شخصيا سعد المجرد لكن
شوفوا انه المغرب لما يتخذ قرارات كامله
يعني حتى في القمه العربيه كثير كانوا
ينتظروا بزياره او مجيء العهد
فيه كبدايه خطوه اوليه يعني اتصالات
وبطلبات حقكم
المساله حرب ايضا على الزعامه في المنطقه
بين الدولتين لاننا همم كنا ننتظر هذه
الزياره للعاهل المغربيه للجزائر العاصمه
ربما ل اا كسر الجليد همم واذابه الجليد
لكن لم تحدث في المقابل العاهل المغربي
دعى بدوره الى الحوار في المغرب يعني على
ارض المغرب يعني وكاننا اصبحنا في اطار
حرب من يستضيف الاخر من اجل الحوار من
يملي شروطه على الاخر يعني هذه علامه
الاستفهام في هذه النقطه
عشنا المرحله
[موسيقى]
الملك فهد
ابن عبد العزيز
يعني ممكن
اذا كانت في خطوه جيده من طرفين حسنه من
الطالب الجزائر
ما يعني القديمه الان زعمرها هتكون زعم
اقتصاديه زعم سياسيه ترجع
لكن على انها تعمل في هذا الاطار وفي هذا
المنحى همم سيد فريد بن يحيى هذا ما
لاحظنا تحدثت عن العلاقات الجزائريه
الافريقيه المغرب ايضا يعمل العالم تحسين
علاقته في العمق الافريقي وتحسين ايضا
العلاقات مع الشركاء
الاوروبيين اذهب الى السيد رفع قطبين في
تونس العاصمه التحق بنا اخيرا سيد رفع
طبيب همم الحديث عن هذه العلاقات المغربيه
الجزائريه شاهدنا تازما كبيرا في الفتره
الماضيه لن نقول غير مسبوق لان العلاقات
المغربيه الجزائريه تشهد دائما مبدا وجذرا
على مدى التاريخ لكن هناك من تحدث عن
خطوره في المرحله همم الماضي او هذه
الفتره الاخيره برايك همم هل يمكن
للدولتين ان تجتازا التوتر وكيف
صحيح ملاحظناها في المده الاخيره هي
الاصطفافات التي
عاشها المغرب العربي عموما ويعيشها في هذه
الفتره الصعبه خاصه في انهيار الوضع في
ليبيا على المستوى السياسي على مستوى
المسار الانتخابي هناك تقارب واضح بين
المراديه وقرطاج
وبروز نوع من انواع التحالف همم السياسي
بين الدولتين في نفس الوقت هناك تسرب ايضا
اسرائيلي الى المنطقه وهناك محاولات يعني
البلدان ان تصب عنها زيت على النار بين
الدولتين شقيقتين وفي نفس الوقت لا ننسى
انه همم هذا همم هذا الصراع بين الدولتين
بين المغرب الشقيق والجزائر الشقيقه اصبح
له تاثيرات همم لا فقط على مستوى المغرب
العربي على المستوى شمال افريقيا وحتى
العمق الافريقي وهذا همم
همم اليوم على المنطقه الانسحاب الفرنسي
محاوله افريقيا بان تلعب دور استراتيجي
يحاول اعاده ترتيب الاوضاع الامنيه في ال-
في المنطقه والعسكريه اضافه ان هناك دول
اخرى مثل الصين الى الخليه التي تحاول ان
تخترق المنطقه وتصبح لها اليد العليا على
المستوى الاقتصادي وحتها المستوى السياسي
بالتالي علينا ان همم نحاول تفتيك هذه هذا
هذا الصراع حتى نتمكن على الاقل من تحيد
ال- همم الجوارب الاكثر خطوره في وخاصه
همم
التدخلات الخارجيه ثم احاولت وجود ايجاد
بعض الحلول همم فيما يهمنا الحدود
[ضحك]
ومحاولت تشريك ايضا الدول التي لها مصلحه
في ان يقف هذا الصراع مثل بعض البلدان همم
شمال المتوسط وايضا البلدان المغرب العربي
تتحدث عن الحلول همم تحدثت عن اشتراك بعض
الدول التي تكمن لها مصالحه في اا انهاء
النزاع لكن كيف عمليا هل ترى انت باعتبارك
طبعا همم استاذ في العلوم الجيوسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه هل ترى مخرجا لهذا
التوتر لهذه العلاقات المتزنه منذ اربعه
عقود بالواقع ليس فقط منذ سنه او سنه ونصف
اولا همم
الحلول الموجوده وهي همم يجب ان تتجاوز
هذه الانتفاءات همم على كل على كل طرف يجب
ان يتم ايجاد همم منطقه عاصمه يمكن ان
تكون هي مقر همم
لمفاوضات بين الطرفين فانت تكون مفاوضات
سريه في البدء ثم يتم تتويجها بالقاء
الزعيمين ثم ثانيا هناك مصالح حقيقه مصالح
اليوم يمكن ان توحد بين البلدين مساله
مثلا اشتراك همم الغاز اليوم نحو اوروبا
وما يمكن ان يقدمه همم المغرب العربي وحسن
الجزائر والمغرب وتونس كاميرات المناطق
عبور نحو نحو اوروبا يمكن ان تكون حقيقه
هي احدى
النقاط الاساسيه
ايقاف هذا التصعيد العسكري الذي اردنا ان
كلامنا لا يساهم فيه في تنميه البلدين
فاذا اتفاق نحو التسرع جانبا وفتح
نعم سباق الحافه السلاح والسباق نحو فتح
البلدين لتدخلات خارجيه ومما يسمى بال
معناها همم الدول التي تقدم من نصح وهمم
الخبره في في التسريح هذه يجب ايقافه لانه
بلداننا اليوم بحاجه الى التنميه والخروج
من منكم زيد والخروج من كل الازمات التي
يشهدوها العالم اليوم لا يمكن ان تكون همم
معناها مجديه اذا ما توجهنا نحو التسلل
هذه اوروبا وما ادراك اوروبا نحو التسلح
ثم قالت انه هذا سيكون له فمن ظاهر جدا
على المستوى الاجتماعي والسياسي وبالتالي
لا يمكن نحن فيما تقتنع بالعربي ان تقبل
بهذا التصعيد الى الرباط
اشار الى اوروبا وانا هنا همم ربما استشهد
بالمثال الفرنسيه الالماني الدولتان خبطت
همم حربين عالميتين همم وفي الاخير في
يقعد عطاء اليد في اليد
وقررت بناء الاتحاد الاوروبي معا هل يمكن
ان نرى المغرب والجزائر في يوم من الايام
تصنعاني نفس الشيء وباي شروط
بين فرنسا والمانيا ليست فقط حربان
عالميان هناك ايضا 1870 حرب بسمارك التي
كانت سببا في الحرب العالميه الاولى اواخر
القرن 19 ال- اا بين المغرب والجزائر هما
قوتان اساسان في المنطقه وفي القاده
الافريقيه اعطي رقمين فقط عدد السكان
المغرب والجزائر 81 مليون سنه كتله بشريه
صوت اقتصاديه هامه جدا للصناعات الوطنيه
سواء في الجزائر او تونس او المغرب وحتى
لما الان شداد
وموريتانيا مجموع همم الناتج الداخلي
الخام للبلدين 2004 و90 مليار دولار
سياتيان في المرتبه الثانيه بعد نيجيريا
نيجيريا هي القوه الاقتصاديه الاولى في
القاره الافريقيه هناك تكامل اقتصادي
واندماج صناعي خصوصا ما يعرف المغرب على
مستوى الصناعات التكنولوجيا صناعه
السيارات صناعه الطائرات الى غير ذلك
فاحتضرونات الان هناك لبدايه صناعه برونات
في المغرب فبالتالي همم لو اتحد المغرب
والجزائر لا خلق قوه اقتصاديا لن تعود
بالنفع على الناتج داخل الخام التي سيرتفع
بنقطتين بل سينتد ايضا الى تونس تونس مع
كامل للاسف الان تعاني ازمات متعدده
الاوجه ليبيا انتم تعرفون ماذا يجري في
ليبيا اخواننا في موريتانيا
من هذا التحالف فبالتالي همم ما الذي يمنع
السؤال الذي سيدتي هام جدا ما الذي يمنع
من هذه والتي قد تبدو بسيطه
الوصول الى
طاوله مفاوضات كيفما كان شكلها اينما حلت
هذه الطاولات اييه المغرب طرح غيرنا مره
يعني ما نقول له شيء اكثر من خطاب الملك
الملك هو السلطه العليا في البلاد عبر غير
ما مر الملك صادق في تعبيره كانت هناك
وسطات اولى هذه الوسطات السعوديه قبيل
القمه العربيه
سمعنا ان هناك رفضا للوساسه السعوديه هناك
تدخل فرنسي على مستوى لان ما يجري ليس حبا
في المغرب والجزائر تونس لانه هناك
انعكاسات سلبيا على اوروبا الغربيه بخصوص
فرنسا كان هناك تدخل اعتقد ان فرنسا الان
تحاول على الاقل خلق موازين قوى بين في
علاقتها مع الاطراف لكي تتمكن من الدخول
الى مستوى بدء الاقل وسطات لكن انا في
نظريه هذه الوصفات لن تصل الى نتيجه لان
الاشكال كما قلت هو اشكال بناء الدوله في
المنطقه واشكال المشروعيه الديمقراطيه
واشكال متعدد الواجهات فبالتالي سؤال ليس
مطروح على المغرب بقدر ما هو مطروح على
الاطراف
الى الى مستوى
هناك طرفان في هذا النزاع لماذا لن لماذا
لا نطرح السؤال على المغرب
باختصار ارجوك سيد موسى
قال سيدتي نحن نقترح اليا ونطرق للطرف
الجزائري ان يحدد كن وطبيعه هذه
المغرب قال للسعوديه نعم نحن نريد دخول في
صلح مع الجزائر همم اسالوني يعني الاطراف
الاخرى وربنا الايام القادمه قد تكشفوا ما
نقول الان
طيب في هذه النقطه تحديدا نسال الدكتور
فريد بن يحيى من الجزائر العاصمه ااا
استمعت الى ما قاله السيد الموسوي
العجلاوي مساله الحوار اول التقاء عند
نقطه معينه الا تقتضي عدد من التنازلات
من الجزائر
في المغرب يتكلم على خطاب
الملك غير كافي بالنسبه السلطات الجزائريه
يعني
طالب مقابله
الملك المغرب على انه وبارك الطريق في هذا
المرفوض تمام شروطه الجزائريه الجزائر
اول مرحله
اول مره بين الجزائر والمغرب هو عدم وجود
الثقه
الاول احمد بن بلاغه
نتكلموا على القمر هذا لابد من رجوع
الثقاب اذا رجعت الثقه بالنسبه للجزائرين
السلطه الجزائريه
انه الجزائر المغرب الجزائر لا تريد مساجد
المغربيه يعني
انفصال القبائل يقول بان الجزائر اصلا
تدعم جبهه البوليساريو الانفصاليه
لا بالنسبه لنا هذا هذا هو الاشكال نحن
بالنسبه
هي الصحراء المشكله بالنسبه للمنطقه
المغربيه
يعني كان في حرب الرمال
الى المغرب وهذا الشيء
لكن عموما هل تعتقد ان التنازلات ممكنه من
الطرفين الان باختصار سيد فريد بن يحيى
لحتى نمر الموضوع الثاني هل تعتقد ان
التنازلات ممكنه حاليا من اجل اصلاح
العلاقات
مهما كانت الحروف وصلت الى القمه بتاعها
لكن
مفاوضات ممكن لكن على المغرب انه يعترف
باخطائه
حقيقي يعني يقبل الانتقادات من طرف الاخر
العلاقات
مع الاسف على كل حال نمر الى الموضوع
الثاني طبعا تازم العلاقات المغربيه
الجزائريه في السياق عالمي يشهد عوده صوره
شبيهه باستقدام الحرب البارده بفعلها
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيا لكن الدول
المغاربيه
على اعطاء انطباع بعد عدم الانحياز خاصه
خلال تصويتها في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لكن الحرب كان لها تدعكت ابرز
واكبر وناسيا في المجاري الاقتصادي ومجال
الطاقه الى اي مدى صارت الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على الدولي المغاربه وايضا على
تحالفاتها من الجهات الجيرو السياسيه وهل
من مستفيد او متضرر اكثر من الاخر في هذه
الحرب سيد رافع طبيب اذهب اليك في تونس
العاصمه معك هل تعتقد بان الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيا كانت لها تدعيات كبيره على دول
مغربيه كما شاهدنا بالنسبه لدول اخرى مثلا
وما هو همم الضرر ابرز الذي شكلته او
الاستفاده الابرز التي شكلت هذه الحرب
بالنسبه للمنطقه المغربيه
نعم هناك نوع من التفاوت في التعامل مع
تاثيرات الحرب الاوكرانيه الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
الجزائر استفادت بشكل كبير وتم اعاده
اعتبار دور الجزائر على المستوى
البحر الابيض المتوسط كقوه محوريه
البلدان الاخرى تضررت بشكل مباشر بهذه
الحرب ولكن هناك قدرات اليوم بدات تفتح
امام العديد من البلدان فمثلا المغرب
وتونس همم هم الاكثر البلدان التي سيتم
التعامل معهما في مساله الفوسفات يعني
مجيد ان الهند والسين قررها همم الرجوع
الى همم
ما يسمى الاكتفاء الذاتي همم الغذائي وهذا
يعني انه ستكون هناك طلب كبير على
الفوسفات في في هذه في هذه البلدين
العملاقين وبالتالي ستكون هناك استفاده في
الاعلى على المداء المتوسط والبعيد ولكن
المشكله هو انا لم نتحذر
لهذه الحرب بللي
ديمومه هذه الحرب اذا ما دامت هذه الحرب
سنوات اخرى في المستقبل ونحن لم نتحذر على
مستوى بلدان على مستوى الغذائي على
المستوى التبادل همم
الاقتصادي على مستوى السياحه نحن نعلم
جيدا انه في الفتره مثلا الشتويه همم
المغرب وتونس ستتحولين الى وجهتان وفضلتان
للاوكران وعدد البلدان في روسيا وغيره من
بلدان همم وسطت وشرق وشرق اوروبا مع كل
اسف اليوم هذا اصبح مستحيل ولكن هناك هناك
ايضا همم قدرات كان يمكن ان همم في
علاقه بما يسمى اليوم
الانتقال التعقيم هناك مثلا المانيا اليوم
تفكر جديا في نقل العديد من صناعات الى
دول حيث تكون هناك الطاقه همم باقل اثمان
ما مثل تونس مثل الجزائر مثل غيرها ولكن
لم نتحدث نحن الى هذه الفرضيه اضافه انه
هناك مشكله كبرى اليوم تطرحوه هو انه عديد
من الدول وخاصه امريكا تفرض على الدول اا
في كل البذل وخاصه في افريقيا وخاصا على
المستوى الوطن العربي
الى جانب امريكا في هذه الحرب في حين انه
لاحظنا انه اليوم ايضا هناك تصلب من طرف
الصين
حيادها البراغماتيه كما يسميها البعض
امامها دخلت في همم هذا السيناريو سيناريو
الى حد الان لما لم يكن هناك اصطفاف بشكل
عمليتي وانا لسنا في حاله ايران او في
حاله بلدان اخرى راينا هناك بلدان اليوم
اصبحت تستغل هذه الحرب
لابراز قدراتها الدفاعيه والتسريحيه مثلا
ايران بينت بشكل كبير انها لها قدرات
خارقه على المستوى ما يسمى المسيارات
الانتحاريه الى اخره لا نحن لا ندخل الى
هذه المعركه بل اكثر من ذلك لحظنا ان هناك
ايضا البلدان حاولت مثلا المغرب او
الجزائر ان همم تستغل هذه الحرب التي تبين
ايضا انها قادر ان تكون لها موقف متوازن
الجزائر قالت انا لا اعوض الغاز الروسي
ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لنا المغرب الذي له
قدرات على المستوى الفوسفات والذي قال
ايضا احاول ان ادخل في نوع من انواع
التنفس مع روسيا في مساله او في بعض
المنتجات الاخرى همم الرضيفه وهذا يبين
انه بلدان الى حد الان تحاول ان تكون
النوع من همم
الانتظار ان ينجلي غبار هذه المعركه حتى
تتمكن من اعاده بناء استراتيجتها ولكن
يبدو انه
المتسارعين اليوم بداوا في التقارب وهناك
حديث حتى عن اتفاق سياسي سيتم الاعلان عنه
في ال- في الفتره اللي لاحقه بعد ان يتم
تظهير كل المعطيات
واتمنى ان لا نكون نحن في منطقه في
المنطقه الاوسع على الوطن العربي هم معنا
من سنتفع هذه الفاتوره هذه الارتفاع هذا
هذا سؤال مهم نقطه مهمه الى السيد الموسوي
العجلاوي بالنسبه فاتوره هذه الحرب انا
ساتحدث عن فاتوره الحج وهذه الاشهر التي
انقضت هل كانت فاتوره ثقيله بالنسبه للدول
المغاربيه انت في المغرب مثلا مساله
الغذاء مساله الامن الغذائي مساعدات
الطاقه همم كيف تعلق على هذه النقطه
الحرب الروسيا الاوكرانيه والحرب بين
روسيا واوروبا كانت نتائجها ثقيله وخيمه
قويه كبيره على اوروبا
وبالاحراد والقاره الافريقيه وبالاحرار
دول شمال افريقيا انتي سيدتي في باريس
الان هناك ما يقوم بانه قطع الكهرباء
هي التي تخلق الشعوب القويه وتبرز الشعوب
القويه في هذه المرحله كيف تتعامل الدوله
مع الشاب حاجيات شعب الشعب في هذه
المنعطفات التاريخيه كما هو الحال في
الكوفيين انت كما هو الحال في ازمه
الثقافه في ازمه الغداء الى غير ذلك
تساليني عن المغرب المغرب كان هناك عمل
استباقيه منذ عقدين تقريبا بدا ما يسمى
الطاقه الشمسيه والطاقات البديله
الانتقال الطاقاوي كل المصطلحات الان التي
اصبحت توظف في الاعلام الدولي
للتعبير عن تجاوز ازمات الغاز
والبترول الروسي المغرب هناك محطه ورزازات
هناك محطه متعدده الان وصل نسبه التغطيه
35% من الطاقه
ستفرض همم
كربون
والصناعات المغربيه والصناعات الغذائيه
كلها الان تتحول الى الطاقات البديله هناك
اهتمام كبير من بريطانيا بطاقات البديله
في المغرب
عزيزه تعاونه مع روسيا في مجال الطاقه
النوويه خلال الاشهر الاخيره
انا كم شروع لانه تحليه ماء البحر لانه مع
ال ايضا لا يجب ان ننسى هذه الازمات اصبحت
متقاطعه لكنه هناك الازمه المناخ ازمه
طاقه ازمه الغداء فالمغرب يفكر في استغلال
الطاقه النوويه من اجل تحليه ماء البحر
لان الامطار لم تعد كما كانت سابقات
تزورنا باستمرار هناك جفاء كما هو الحال
الجفاء الحاسن بيننا وبين اخونا في
الجزائر الامطار ايضا غاب عني المنطقه
هناك الفوسفات الذي له اهميته تعريفين
جيدا ان هناك السماد المشتق من الفوسفات
المغربي همم يعني مش كيس 97%
الاحتياطات الدوليه هناك صناعه قويه كبيره
جدا المغربي يلعب مع نيجيريا اثيوبيا
والجابون بلي همم
كما قلت ان الازمات هي من تخلق الدول
القويه والشعوب القويه هل تعتقد بان هذه
الازمه همم ربما دافعت المغربي الى اعاده
النظر سواء في امنه الغذائي وتحضير له
جيدا في علاقاته مع المحيط سواء في العمق
الافريقيه وحتى مع الشركاء الاوروبيين
التقليديين وكيف ذلك باختصار ارجوك
سيدتي عندما تذهبين الى اي همم سوبر مارشي
تبحثين عن الخضر المغربيه لانها لذيذه جدا
المغرب يصدر الخضر والفواكه الى اوروبا
الى افريقيا
مشكل فقط الحبوب فال همم
حبذا لو كان اعود الى التعاون المغاربين
حبذا لو كانت هناك توافق
الان رد عربي توفي منذ زمن طويل لكان هناك
ردود فعلا
ازمات بشكل يستفيد منها المواطن المغاربيه
مع كامل اسف هذه الازمات تحد من استفاده
المواطن المغاربي من هذه الانتاجات
المندبجه المتكامله السيد فريد بن يحيى في
الجزائر العاصمه هناك من يقول او قال
السيد رفعت في الواقع في بدايه هذا
الموضوع ان الجزائر استفادت من هذه الحرب
ااا استطاعت ان تساوم او تفاوض الاوروبيين
بشان غازلها
وخرجت رابحه ما تعليقك بدايه على هذه
النقطه وعن افاق تدعيجات هذه الحرب على
المنطقه المغاربيه واليست التي تعد هذه
الحرب ربما فرصه
لاتمام التكامل المغاربي
او المملكه العربيه السعوديه
نقطه اخرى كذلك بالنسبه
للقانون الماليه 98 مليار دولار حوالي
تقريبا 100 مليون اكبر
من الشركات الاوروبيه الان التي تستهلك
كثيرا من الطاقه
شركه المانيا او حتى ممكن
الجزائر في هذا المجال همم
استخداماتها في مضاعفات ميزانيه الجيش
الجيش بالنسبه للاخوه في المغرب
اذا عندك كثير من المشاكل
النقطه الثانيه كذلك
يعني
صناع الصالون الصناعات همم
الجزائر ذهب الى صناعه وصناعه الطالب
استثمارات فالهدف انت عن نهايه 22 مليار
دولار ليس الى المغرب يعني
الامر هذاك يعني كتهديد لهم نحن جزائريين
لا نريد تهديد المغرب ولا تهددنا احنا
ندافعوا الحدود
في عهد معمر القذافي ليبي يستغل يعني نوعه
يعني
[موسيقى]
يعني كميه كبيره من المياه
من العراق
منطقه مغربيه
في المنطقه سنخص بذكره تونس همم نتحدث عن
الاوضاع السياسيه
الربيع العربي تشهد منذ سنه
جديده
بعد اجراءاتها الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
الاستثناء همم هناك من يعتبر مسار
انقلابيا هناك من يعتبره مساءا تصحيحياجا
لثوره 2011 على كل حال الاستقط حاد جدا في
تونس الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره التي
شهدت البلاد شهدت نسبه مقاطعه قياسيه لم
تشهد هل البلاد في تاريخها في تاريخها
تونس الى اين بعد ان كانت المثال الامل
كما يقول كثيرون تونس الى اين تتجه الان
دكتور رافع همم انطلق من حيث
انتهت تطورات السياسيه في تونس هذه
الانتخابات التشريعيه همم مع الاسف شهيده
مقاطعه قياسك على ماذا يدل هذا برعيك
لا ليست مقاطعه هي عزوف هناك فرق لانه في
الصيف الفارطه كانت كان هناك استفتاء
وشركه في حوالي 3-3 ملايين من الناخبين
وتبين بالكشف انه هناك حقيقه اراده لدى
شعب التونسي ان يسير في هذا التوجه الجديد
فيما بعد 25 جويليه ولكن اللحظه اليوم في
تونسيه لحظه اقتصاديه اجتماعيه هناك ازمه
اجتماعيه خارقه في تونس اليوم هناك همم
تحالف بين اللوبيات وشبكات المصالح في
تونس تريد ان تجرح هذا الشعب وتركعه حتى
نعود الى مربع ما قبل 25 جويليه اي الفتره
التي كانت فيها همم اللوبيات المسرحيه هي
التي تتحكم في الاحزاب وهي تتحكم في همم
همم الدفق الديناميكي للعمليه السياسيه
هذا ال- هذا الشيء اصبح اليوم مستحيل ولكن
بالمقابل هناك رئيس اعطيت له كل همم
صلاحيات حتى يتمكن من ااا انجاز الاسلحه
والمطالب الشعبيه التي عبرت عنها انتفاخ
25 جويه ل 2021 الرئيس لم يحقق هذه
الانجازات بل اكثر من ذلك له زمنيه لا
تتوافق مع زمنيه الشارع التونسي اعطى كل
الوقت للاحزاب التي اخرجها شعبه تونسي من
السلطه حتى تمكن من اعاده تنظيم صفوفها
تفرض نفسها عبر اعلان الجميع يعلم ان معنا
انه همم تاب عليه اللوبيات وتابع
للمجموعات المسرحيه هناك نوع من انواع
التسيب على المستوى الاداره في تونس
الاداره اصبحت تتحكم في كل المفاصل الدوله
يعني ايا كانت الكلمه التي المصطلح التي
نستخدمه هو انعدام الثقه بالنهايه في
الطبقه السياسيه سواء كانت احزاب او حتى
رئيس قصص سعيد هناك من كان ينتظر منه
الكثير خلال
والنصف المنقضيه لكنه همم لم يفعل شيء انا
يعني مثلا كنت في تونس مؤخرا سالت
التونسيين هناك همم
غياب وانعدام همم تاملي ثقه في الطبقه
السياسيه
طبعا ما ما تفضلت بقوله بانها هو عين
الحقيقه المشكله اليوم في تونس انه همم
الناس سوت همم انكفات
وعزفت عن المشاركه في الانتخابات لا لا لي
همم
وقوفا الى جانب المعارضه بل لانه الرئيس
رفض ان يعاقب هذه المعارضه التي كانت في
الحكم وهناك نوع من انواع خيبه الامل
الكبرى التي اليوم تشتيح البلاد لان الناس
كانوا حقيقه يؤمنون في فتره من الفترات
انه سيكون هناك اصلاح ولكن هذا الاصلاح
تاخر تاخر كثيرا وبالتالي هذا يجعل الشعب
التونسي يرسل هذه الرساله القويه الى الى
الرئاسه ويعطيها حيز من الزمن قصير جدا
حتى تصلح الامور ولذلك اما اصلاح او
العوده الى السحاب
اصبحنا بالنسبه
والله لست لست مقربا من الرئاسه ولا اعلم
حقيقه ان هذا المطبخ السيسي كيف يشتغل
ولكن يمكن ان يؤكده لك سيدتي ان هناك
حقيقه الضغط وهناك اصوات لها نوع من
الحضور في تونس ولها حيثيه حقيقه لدى
الرئاسه تحدث في الفتره الاخيره
وترحت حقيقه هذا الخوف وهذا الجزاء من طرف
الشارع التونسي اذا هذا همم
التململ الكبير اليوم داخل داخل شارع
التونسي الذي رفض
الانتفاضه الجوع ضد قيس سعيد ولكنه ايضا
عاقب هذا المسار عبر هذا الانتفاء وهذا
العزوف انتفاضه الجوع يقول السيد رافع
الطبيب من تونس العاصمه سيد مساوي
العشلاوي هل يمكن ان نشهد انتفاضه تجوع في
تونس
يعني خاصه اننا راينا في هذه الانتخابات
الطوابير بالنسبه للمحروقات او الاهتمام
بلقمه العيش اكبر بكثير من الاقتراع
هي الصوره ابلغ من اي تحليل من اي مقال
صوره التي تجري الان في شارع الجزائر
العمق ابتعدي شيئا ما الى الجنوب من تونس
او الى الجنوب الغربي او الشرقي او الجنوب
بصفه عامه ستجدين تونس اخ اخرى فبالتالي
الاشكال الان في تونس ما هو الاشكال هو ان
تونسي سئم الفوضى لمده 10 سنوات
افق سياسي جديد لان عاكس ايجابا على
الشباب بالخصوص وعلى المواطن التونسي
ال كانت هناك حاجه الى سلطه مركزيه قويه
تخرج تونس من تلك الفوضى التي كانت شائعه
منذ قبل وصول قيس سعيد ولذلك الناس
صوتوا على قيس سعيد وصوتوا على بعض
المقترحات على اساس ان ينعكس ذلك على
اليوم مع كامل الاسف هذه هي المعادله هل
يستطيع قيس سعيد ان يلبي حاجيات المواطن
التونسي مع كامل اسف الوضع التونسي منها
الصندوق النقد الدولي لم يطرح مساله القرد
منذ يومين على طاوله اجتماعيه الاخير هناك
همم الرئاسه الجزائريه التي تدخل بين
الفين والاخرى ملايين الدولارات من انقاذ
اليومي في في تونس هل الاقتصاد تونس قادر
على الاستجابه الى كل ما يمكن ان يطلبه
المواطن لا اعتقد اذا فشل قيس سعيد في
استجابه الى حاجيات المواطن اليوميه فانه
بالتاكيد سيفشل المقاطعه او العزوف كما
قال صديقنا من تونس مهما كانت توصيف هي
رساله قويه هل تلتقط لا ادري باي سيلتقطها
قيسيد ما هي وسائل ماليه ما هي الوسائل
الاقتصاديه المؤسسات التي يمكن من خلالها
تحت الامور الى ان الاجابه على هذه
المعادله الصعبه جدا بالنسبه لتونس يعني
فقط
في العالم العربي
صحيح اذهب الى السيد فريد بن يحيى واختم
معك في موضوع تونس مع الاسف لن يسعى ان
الوقت الحديث عن ليبيا لان الوقت انتهى
اييي قيس سعيد هل يمكن ان يلتقط هذه
الرساله كما تساءلت انا وضيفيا من تونس
ومن المغرب
والى اين يمكن ان تتجه الاوضاع خاصه في ظل
هذا التدهور الاقتصادي والاسما
اقتصاديات في الجزائر الان
يعني الاموال اللازمه يعني الاخوه
التونسيين لكن بالنسبه لنا انه القيس سعيد
عم العام الجبار لانه لما نتكلم على
الدستور يعني همم
فهذا لا ينجح في العالم العربي عنده
سنتين عنده رئيس
نظام رجل قوي سواء كان سلطان الجمهوريه
يكون عنده الصلاحيه شفنا انه كان حتى
وان شاء الله تكون سخنه امتحان مهمه
بن هو سايبنا من الخطب العاصمه يعني نستمع
الى رئيس قيس سعيد يخرج يلقي خطابات لكن
عمليا على ارض الميدان لا يحصل شيء
تونس
الروسيه المشاكل الموجوده في اوروبا
الكبير
دكتور فريد بن يحيى يكون سمعنا من الجزائر
العاصمه اشكر ايضا السيد رفعت وي بنت تونس
العاصمه والدكتور موساوي العشواوي من
الرباط وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه
الحلقه الخاصه من النقاش المغاربه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]